hey feminists stop please stop okay so
I'm sure we've all heard the Patricia
Arquette Oscar speech it's our time to
have wage equality once and for all
and equal rights now before we get to
the gender gap pay myth and it is a myth
a quick message to feminists this is why
people can't stand you including women
too many neo feminists are illogical
angry and oh so shrill here you've been
given a platform to graciously accept an
award instead he decide to spout off
some inappropriate political message
even though it's completely untrue and
all your silly feminist buddies clap
like trained seals in the United States
of America
when you're wrong about something and
Arquette is wrong here people just don't
want to tell you out of fear for facing
the cackling ramifications of you and
your butch haircut a chain gang see now
you've become bullies because god forbid
we express a different opinion you ask
questions but on to the Equal Pay gender
gap myth please note in this instance
will not actually be including the full
51 genders available today but the main
to because you know science the myth
that women get paid less for the exact
same job as men comes from one poorly
interpreted statistic that merely
compares the median earnings of women
versus men that stat did not include
people of different genders working in
the same industry the same job or even
the same amount of hours so the pay gap
myth is untrue for a few reasons but
let's start with simple economics if I'm
a business owner and I can get away with
paying a woman half of what I pay a man
for the exact same job I'm never hiring
a man again I'd start hiring on cup size
and fire every last chuan tan on staff
if only to increase profits step into my
office fired what about the patriarchal
sexism in the workplace firstly men like
women okay a lot it's not like we had a
secret meeting behind your back in this
world even if there were men hiring
solely based on their chauvinistic
worldview which kind of goes against the
whole evil capitalism maximizing profits
myth it only takes one person who
doesn't to create a competitive job
market place so why are women paid less
the number one determining factor is
that women have babies are you saying
that's all we're good for no just that
in general women are the ones found to
be with child
you know wombs and what-have-you so not
only does that mean less time in the
workforce but women are also more likely
to trade in dangerous job situations
high-stress or traveling in exchange for
more mommy friendly positions it's why
virtually all the most dangerous job
occupations like iron worker the logger
are male a 92% of work-related deaths in
2012 were men so you may complain about
lower pay we die
in addition men are twice as likely to
work a 40-hour workweek
we drove around all day and there's not
a single job in this town there's
nothing nada zip yeah unless you want to
work 40 hours a week then on average
work 8.1 four hours per day compared to
women's average 7.75 more men are in
unions more men are willing to have
extensive travelling schedules you can
check up more data at allowed or with
Crider comm but the point is that buzz
phrases like equal pay don't have to be
rooted in reality as long as there are
enough people who scream it loudly
enough in this case shrews like Meryl
Streep who I cannot stand
I know it's sacrilegious I'm just tired
of being told who the best actress is
just like I'm tired of people telling
you Scarlett Johansson is super hot fly
face mediocre talent with a man voice
does not the hottest woman in America
make be like kissing Darth Vader and I
know about that kind of life I'm just a
starving actress from Boulder Colorado
for the last time right back to the
point I had a point despite what
terribly ill informed people like Meryl
Streep or Patricia Arquette tell you the
reason that women make less in today's
workplace is because of economic
decisions not penises hey watch this
last video or subscribe to my channel
all of you are welcome men women though
if you're a woman it's preferable to
bring a sandwich